I live an amazing life but where was
that there are we heard about two or
three people getting stabbed left right
and Center we go to them clubs and we
have the best time ever and we know
girls out there they're gonna have a
great time Dubai is
I can walk around Dubai yeah with a with
a with a handful of diamonds like this
and no one will touch me I can walk
around East London with a handful of
diamonds like that and they'll be gone
within about 10 seconds right so Dubai I
know girls that went to Dubai mate and
they've been harassed left right and
Center in the clubs by white boys London
boys Birmingham boys no matter where
you're from but it doesn't matter where
you are as long as there's geezers here
I don't care who you are what
environment private event good event I
don't care where you are
in a minute so wait a minute you're
trying to tell me that anywhere women go
yeah enjoy them wait a minute
anywhere that women go and they're men
there yeah
no
because what you're doing is you're
gonna you're gonna demonize Men You're
Gonna demonize men you two as men should
not be saying anywhere that man is
hostile I'm not gonna have no no no no
no no no no no
wait a minute it can be it does not mean
it is there's a difference in the word
so so let's not do that wait a minute
when a girl was on the show and she said
that Owen in my welcome majority of men
no but you know do you know what the
majority is we never said the majority
no no no he said in in Dubai it's the
safest place
I'm a man and you're saying when these
men is hostile I'm saying no no can be
is different from it being hostile if
you choose to put yourself in a place
that is dangerous and hostile you accept
some responsibility for your behavior if
I'm your man and you put yourself in a
place where man I grab
wait a minute wait a minute not every
single place you go to his life
thank you you're trying to say right
yeah but Auntie what I'm saying to you
right what you're trying to what you're
saying is bro you're saying is if you're
putting yourself if the girls are
putting themselves in a situation of the
guys where grabby grabby it shouldn't be
happening hang on a second I know girls
that go to places and situations that
aren't grabby grabby that aren't
renowned for that sort of [ __ ] unless
but that's not what we're talking about
yeah
there's a difference between going to a
club and getting hit on and rejecting it
time and time again right there's
difference in going out okay and there's
a difference from going somewhere where
you are describing it as hostile for
example I went to Carnival and I found
it very hostile because when I said no
to guys they got aggressive but I'm not
going to go around and say oh it's just
hostile but it can be okay will you go
there again yeah I would still in the
same situation again I would still go
because it's how I handle myself but
it's hostile would you handle yourself
differently
would you describe Carnival as being
hosta or saying Carnival can be hostile
very hostile you say it is
an apostle thing going on whether it's
me or not there's always some sort of
hostile situation going on and kind of
why am I right that's why so you're
saying
Carnival can be hostile can be anywhere
no majority of the time not majority
they always use that word majority so
when they don't mean a majority means
like 70 of Carnival is hostile you know
what you're doing you're doing what the
TV what the media do yeah a few people
get um get stabbed in Conor a few things
happen in a cool Carnival this has
happened so the majority of Carnival is
not hostile it's across two days
let me land because I'm not going to
have it because what you're doing is
yeah kind of some bad things happen at
carnival there's some idiots that go to
Carnival we know stabbings happen in
carnival but the most for the most part
you will not see a damn thing for the
two days it tends to be after dark about
nine o'clock when the things start to
happen so Carnival is not a hostile
Place
wait guys sorry
the only reason I mentioned Carnival is
because I'm saying because we're talking
about hostile environment so I'm saying
we could class that as but I still go so
that's not good
wait a minute the difference is is that
now she's saying it can be you're
changing
it can be no you said it you said it is
you said it is yeah no I experienced it
but it's because you've experienced it
doesn't mean that what we're trying to
say is like the same for the Moroccan
girls I don't like it we're not saying
Carnival is not hostile Carnival can be
hostile yeah
what I'm trying to say to you is aren't
he any work yeah what am I trying to say
is that anywhere could be like my point
let me put it from this point
as me yeah I go to Carnival if I went to
Carnival and I find it hostile am I
gonna go back no I bet you would no no
no no no no
listen hang in a minute
listen to what I said I said if I went
to Carnival and I found it hostile would
I go back no the key word is hostile
okay I don't care because I you said oh
but you'll be having fun I cannot have
fun enough style environment so I would
not go back
24 7. there could be a moment where you
feel
you feel you know how Carnival it is
then but then you could go around the
corner you could go Rampage for example
I've been Rampage it was very hostile
then when I went to school
no I'm just giving an example I'm giving
an example
there could be a reason
it's a lot of
talking technology thank you it's not
always hostile and there could be an
environment worse you think okay that's
a bit hostile but regardless of that
minute situation you've had a good time
throughout the rest of the day did you
get it so then you want to go so answer
you could go to any I could name you I
could give you a list of 10 clubs I've
been to in our beefar in Vegas in Bali
in London in Maidstone in Ken like that
are all amazing that you could all go to
but I could name every single one of
those that I've seen a punch up I've
seen a stab in I've seen someone's heads
get kicked in like how many times have
you had a good time it's not a hostile
it was a hostile environment at that
time I've been to we are Festival five
six what I'm trying to say is that um I
would not say that it's a hostile
environment you would say that it can be
accepting can be I will not accept that
Carnival is a hostile environment
can be anywhere can be of course
wait let me finish if something or
somewhere yeah is continually in my view
a hostile environment I don't give a
[ __ ] what kind of music they're playing
now
I'm not going yeah because it's already
proven that it's a hostile environment
so I find it really hard that as a woman
that there is nowhere that I can go out
where there's men that is not going to
be hostile because I think you said can
be okay I I accept that aren't you you
can go to certain places and they might
be incidents that's a hospital right
that you might find hostile yeah right
you can live with that but if I keep on
going somewhere where time and time and
time again it is hostile what the hell
am I putting myself
especially as a woman so especially as a
woman the question Auntie though so
let's say that you've gone to Carnival
you've gone to Carnival for the last
five years you have time you do what
you're doing and this one time you go
and you're in a hostile environment you
think oof like I'm in a hostile
environment the next next time it comes
around are you going back even though
you've just been in that one hostile
environment that's why I haven't been my
life's too important that's what I
haven't been that's basically what
happened that is why that and that is
why I wouldn't go back like I said to
you I've been in the flow I've been on
the truck I've been with the DJs I've
been everywhere in carnival and if I was
going to go to Carnival now and I took
my grandkids I would go on a Sunday and
I'd make sure by four o'clock that we're
leaving and that we're gone I refuse to
go Carnival because
let me finish if I was gonna go Carnival
I would buy a costume and I would go in
a float if I really had the need to why
would you finish I would fine pardon why
would you finish at four why did I
finish before
you said you'd be gone by four why
because like I said I'll take my
grandchildren and I think that on a
Sunday and it's coming down all the
Hostile things happened late at night no
late at night I wouldn't be there that I
wouldn't put myself in that situation
because so everybody that keeps on going
Carnival knows that people go Carnival
and they go early
no traditional people oh aren't they I
can't agree no traditional people who
enjoy Carnival would be at carnival of
eight nine ten o'clock at night unless
let me finish okay unless you're with a
sound system with a cook with the bands
with the flow or something like that but
I could give you clubs that we've been
to for if you know what you're wanting a
matter for half a dozen years and we've
had the best nights ever at weekends at
a time but then I've been to that same
club and I've seen people have their
heads kicked in so look I'll still go
there the next time so Mason look look
what is the meaning of a hostile
environment the environment can become
hostile when unwelcome on conduct
harassment it okay
you're stopping me you're stopping I'm
not gonna say to you so if you're in a
hostile environment yeah all these
places we're talking about what hostile
environment is so when you use the word
hostile it's dangerous
so so difference between it can be you
could that's the key word
can I just ask a question when you went
to Carnival and it was hostile what
exactly happened to you that made it
and then when I said no they got they
ended up getting aggressive but
obviously that hasn't happened to me in
previous years so that's why I'm not
saying oh Carnival's hostile I always go
so how many people got aggressive about
at least three so that's not so free out
of how many thousands of people
three people approached you
approaches five ten yeah didn't take no
for an answer no they just kept on yeah
so that makes
no then they started being abusive and
what did you do I just like told them
who was you with my my friends female
friends yeah how many wow foreign why
should that matter honey
why should that matter
shouldn't but we're living in the real
world exactly exactly exactly
that is why that is why I'm saying that
like he was saying as a woman there's
certain situations you put yourself into
because like you're agreeing with me now
these things happen and if you know
these things can happen anywhere
anywhere why would you put yourself in
there
and in a minute they are safer ways of
enjoying Carnival honestly
there are safer ways of enjoying clubs
I'm not going to say that I haven't been
into clubs and they've been fights
exactly I'm not even going to say that I
haven't been to clubs and and maybe got
involved yeah absolutely a couple of
fights myself what I'm going to say is
that I refuse to go into clubs where I
feel that
I don't care where you go we could go
into the normal quiet apartment just so
happens one night the two keys bump into
each other to [ __ ] hate each other
and all hell we're UPS in that club
that's not a hostile environment
that is an incident happening that Pub
is not a hostile environment
so if you went and told me so we often
see that Pub it's hostile but I wouldn't
want to go in there if you told me you
were into that Pub and a fight happened
to break out that's totally different
but we are festivals yeah in the
environment
we are festivals a massive group for
many many US boys love a festival we
love Ghana we love going to clubs love
going all over the country and all over
the world as we are first of all started
to go on over the years it started to
bring in the wrong crowds and we start
to see the wrong stuff happening at that
place and what changed that environment
the people the people that we still went
back Auntie just because that it's not
their environment we love we are busy
days love the music
yeah
it can be I've seen I've seen we've
we've been walking out the end of the
event but I've seen someone covered in
Claret from head to time
do you know something about I think that
my interpretation of hostile and your
interpretation of hostile is totally
different because if I went somewhere
yeah and the fight broke out yeah right
two people in the corner and like
bounces were there and shut it down yeah
yeah yeah as far as I'm concerned yeah
no but I wouldn't turn around and say
they would I that is hostile I was
saying you know what I went out the
other day and they got some idiots there
is what I'm saying to you I don't
believe anywhere it's hostile I just
know [ __ ]
let me speak you guys are capable
hostile was not you are lost style hang
a minute hostile was not my word
hostile was not my words it was
Britney's the young lady's words she's
the one that brought up the word hostile
that she goes out to hostile environment
and the men in there make it hostile
that's where it is so wherever she goes
that's what she's saying yeah that she
wants to go those places and they're
hostile that is why I wanted to know
what hostile meant because she didn't
say these places can be hostile or these
places like now I realize that hervey of
hostile and mine is different because
I'm used to going to Carnival and
they're three or four or 10 men approach
me and they're drunk and it's like yeah
I'll be getting on and that to me that's
not hostile that is it's normal Carnival
Carnival because they got aggressive
obviously I'm just no I'm trying to say
is that with alcohol in them people act
a certain way to me
that still wouldn't be hostile for me I
would not see that as a hostile
environment so our experiences are
different you went to Carnival that
happened to you you said it was hostile
if I went to Carnival I would say I had
a good time there were a few drunken
idiots you know what I mean hostile the
word in general so let's say aggressive
behavior or something but you're
changing it now you didn't say that no
but I didn't say no but you but you went
with it no no but I'm because obviously
that's the word we've surrounded it in
but I'm saying like just in general
drama happening or five yeah I think
that's all because what I'm trying to
say now is that now that word hostile is
removed yeah I can understand why you'd
go back to Carnival yeah yeah I mean
that makes sense because as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible